the trouble with hooker is that she's
got his headquarters where his
hindquarters ought to be a cold-blooded
calculating unprincipled usurper without
a virtue he's a nice guy
but he played too much football with his
helmet Oh Ronald Reagan doesn't dye his
hair he's just prematurely orange
garfield has shown that he's not
possessed of the backbone of an
angleworm a nonentity with side whiskers
his whole life has been one continued
insult to good manners and to decency a
slur upon the moral government of the
world he can compress the most words
into the smallest ideas better than any
man I have ever met
that bastard brat of a Scottish peddler
he's ambition his restlessness in all
his grandiose schemes come I'm convinced
from a super abundance of secretions
which he couldn't find enough [ __ ] to
absorb why this fellow don't know any
more about politics that a pig knows
about Sunday I have only two regrets I
didn't shoot Henry Clay and I didn't
hang John C Calhoun a blind bald
crippled toothless man who's a hideous
hermaphroditical with none of the force
and fitness of a man know all the
gentleness and sensibility of a woman
I remember when BuzzFeed was just
something I did in college around 2:00
a.m.
you